i'm sure you've dreamed about having a
tesla cyber truck how do we know built
like a dream the truck isn't what you
see daily tesla introduced the cyber
truck a light duty truck powered
entirely by electricity and batteries
the epa estimates the range of each
model at 250 to 500 miles this is
something from a movie elon musk
unveiled the all-new tesla cyber truck
on november 21 2019. it doesn't look
anything like anything else he claimed
during a ceremony reminiscent of a steve
jobs presentation and he was
unquestionably correct in his assessment
the truck has a post-apocalyptic feel to
it as well as a distinct cyberpunk
aesthetic it seems like it was built to
survive laser blasts food riots and the
badass acting of nicolas cage the cyber
truck is undoubtedly well known to you
at this point you know it is an electric
vehicle however there are still a lot of
things you're probably not aware of
believe me when i say that these 10
facts about the tesla cyber truck will
surprise you now it's time to dig in as
with anything unfamiliar in novel public
opinion is always divided but it's not
quite the same when it comes to tesla's
genius the cyber truck is outside the
box it's built to be one of the top
commercial and consumer trucks on the
market soon the rear wheel steering the
new cyber truck is allegedly slated to
come with rear wheel steering which
should offer it some more agility in
tight situations musk also said that the
cyber truck will be nearly precisely
what was presented the latter comment is
presumably in reaction to many who have
argued that the audacious design will
never enter production in its original
form the rear wheel steering function on
this vehicle may have been inspired by
the gmc hummer ev's crab walk mode to go
diagonally the hummer's rear wheels can
pivot up to 10 degrees in the same
direction as the front wheels the rear
wheel steering system allows the car to
turn far tighter than its size would
suggest it has a nice bed
the cyber truck bed is 6.5 feet long and
built of stainless steel like the rest
of the truck unlike other pickups the
bed has no wheel wells the side panels
have storage compartments and the
tailgate has a sliding loading ramp for
easy loading the bed includes 120 and
220 volt outlets as well as an air
compressor use the included bed cover to
safeguard the bed's contents which will
also make the truck more aerodynamic
it's got special lighting too the
interior lighting system of the cyber
truck bed allows you to see what you're
doing even when you're sleeping at night
alternatively if you wish to add this
function to another truck you must
purchase and install a kit one of the
post-launch prototypes of the cyber
truck also features an illuminated strip
on the front roof which might be
utilized for emergency lighting in the
event of a power outage solar rooftop
still on the subject of lighting the
tesla cyber truck is equipped with an
energy section that allows for the
charging of electric vehicles and the
reduction of electricity costs for
houses by harnessing the power of the
sun for the cyber truck tesla has said
that a solar roof will be available for
purchase for the vast majority of people
who park outside whether at home or work
it appears to be a viable technique of
making their car work for them while
they are away from the office or home no
range fear
one of the challenges of driving a tesla
is the requirement to replenish the
battery unlike gas stations tesla
charging stations are significantly more
scarce tesla had two responses first
they're introducing a 500 mile stacked
battery option for the cyber truck which
is 35 longer than the model s sedan the
basic pack only lasts 250 miles so it is
essential for long trips second tesla
aims to expand its network of
supercharger stations into more rural
locations making longer trips easier to
recharge a digital mirror is required
for drivers putting it mildly the cyber
truck is a hulking beast with the large
side panels of the bed it is difficult
to look beyond the bed and into the
blind zones to solve this problem the
cyber truck is equipped with a digital
rear view camera it is a screen that
displays a live feed of what is behind
the truck it can go off-road for a
16-inch ground the vehicle incorporates
adaptive air expansion the truck's
length is short making off-roading
difficult mr musk said the truck might
withstand the baja 1000 a tough off-road
event we'll see if it can do that it was
inspired by films musk stated that the
design of the cyber truck was heavily
influenced by two films blade runner and
the spy who loved me musk stated that
the lotus esprit which was featured
prominently in the bond film served as a
major source of inspiration for him it
has a significant amount of power under
the hood
the cyber truck will be equipped with
either one two or three electric motors
depending on how much money you are
ready to spend on it in 6.5 seconds the
single motor vehicle will accelerate to
60 miles per hour and pull a load of up
to 7 500 pounds the double motor truck
can accelerate to 60 miles per hour in
4.5 seconds and tow up to 10 000 pounds
of payload incredibly the triple motor
version can reach speeds of up to 60
miles per hour in 2.9 seconds and tow up
to 14 000 pounds with ease so the cyber
truck is ideal for transporting old
mainframe computers sports cars cases of
1987 cabernet sauvignon and whatever
else its owners want to load into it the
truck allegedly outperformed a ford
f-150 and a porsche
musk took digs at both ford and porsche
during his presentation suggesting that
the cyber truck was superior to both
first he demonstrated a tug of war
between the cyber truck and a ford f-150
even though it was pulling up hill the
cyber truck comfortably outperforms the
f-150 he then displayed a video of the
cyber truck competing in a drag race
against a porsche 911 despite having a
head start the cyber truck rapidly
overtakes it proving its ability to
accelerate to high speeds sundeep madra
vp of ford's experimental branch ford x
responded by tweeting to musk send us a
cyber truck and we will do the apples to
apples test for you bring it on musk
just said so we have the equivalent of
my dad could beat up your dad there are
issues with the windows
this is probably unexpected for a car
that allegedly beat a ford f-150 and a
porsche musk also boasted about the
reinforced and so difficult to breach
windows to establish his argument he had
hull's house and fling steel balls at
the glass not everything went as planned
it's hard to tell from the pictures but
the balls fractured the windows rather
than shattering them musk took to
twitter later in the week to explain why
the windows were broken he went on to
explain that when holzhausen slammed the
door with a sledgehammer the base of the
glass fractured jeopardizing the
integrity of the glass itself a video of
the truck passing the same test before
it was unveiled was then shown and the
truck was declared the winner over 250
000 pre-orders
as of now musk claims that tesla has
gotten more than 250 000 pre-orders for
the truck without employing any
sponsored advertising or endorsements
okay they aren't pre-orders but they're
close enough reservations would be a
better word for only one hundred dollars
tesla is allowing consumers to pre-order
the cyber truck with the final price
ranging from thirty nine thousand nine
hundred dollars to forty nine thousand
nine hundred dollars to sixty nine
thousand nine hundred dollars plus an
additional seven thousand dollars for
the self-driving option it is important
to note that this does not imply that
tesla has sold a large number of trucks
when it comes time to make the final
payment we should expect some of these
pre-orders to be cancelled the number of
cyber trucks ordered by musk aficionados
who don't have the cash to spend 45 000
on a vehicle is impossible to estimate
the police want it several police
departments around the world are
interested in the tesla cyber truck in
addition some of these police
departments have attempted to reserve a
few units for their fleet before the
pre-order window closes on december 1st
ciudad valles in san luis potosi mexico
placed one of the most recent pre-orders
for our tesla cyber truck which was
delivered in december in an interview
with ellen parcell mayor adrian esper
cardenas revealed that he had placed an
order for 15 tesla cyber trucks which
will be used primarily by the
municipality's police force according to
the municipal mayor because of the
truck's speed and strength the vehicles
will also be used for some heavy duty
tasks such as pulling water pipes and
garbage containers from underground
storage tanks when tesla unveiled this
brilliant cyber truck design in november
2019 many people mistook it for a joke
especially in the first week the
appearance made it appear impossible to
have these outstanding qualities it
appears to be fairly colorless minimal
and has a standard design appearance
because the vehicle is made up of flat
planes some observers concluded it had a
childish and careless appearance you may
be asking if this is inventive or a
gimmick which is it right now it is
difficult to determine whether the cyber
truck represents a revolution or a
marketing stunt whether it will be a
game changer for the trucking business
or just a fancy car that appeals mostly
to tesla devotees remains to be seen one
thing is certain the vehicle is unlike
anything we have ever seen before except
in the movies and we have to give elon
musk some credit for that as said at the
beginning of the video it's just a
stroke of genius but also dreamy what
are the cyber trucks other interesting
features is it the best truck ever leave
us a comment with your thoughts and if
you enjoyed this video make sure to give
it a like and check out more awesome
ones on the simply tech channel thanks
for watching and we'll see you next time